guenther est probablement le tueur à
gages de plus redouté de tous
aujourd'hui si on veut devenir roi il
faut tuer le roi
tout le monde sait qu'ils gagnent tard
gunter
mais moi je suis là
surprise c'est un des tueurs à gages les
plus réputés je serai l'homme
providentiel qui aura tué guenther j'ai
mis sur pied une équipe qui n'a peur de
rien on va couper au montage
je m'appelle donald 19 ski boum boum
boum ça mérite bien son surnom comme
boum c'est la dynamite
je m'appelle sanaa fait rose à la toute
première fois que j'ai tué quelqu'un
j'avais huit mois je m'appelle isat
j'écrase des trucs
nous avons une arme secrète redoutable
s'appellent ak la kova d'enfoirés de
jumeaux on adore écrit ci
non en fait chier faut que je trouve une
fenêtre quand j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait toute une bande d'assassins qui
avait l'intention de me tuer j'avoue que
ça m'a agacé ça très mal commencé
je crois que j'ai encore plus envie de
le tuer après tout ça on y va
on est totalement dépassé par les
événements le rugby à ix j'ai un tueur à
gages vous balancez il matto newey
spinale exact j'ai fait du centre se
mettent non tu vas essayer de le tuer
pour la énième fois de me bazooka tu
veux faut vraiment qu'on soit au taquet
je crois que c'est fini
je les écraserait ces fumiers garantie
sur facture allez vas-y tu vois
[Musique]